[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to LED live
where we use the Light of Christ to
expose some Darkness but today we're
going to actually shed some light on not
necessarily a dark and evil and Ault
topic but something that I believe
everybody deals with and that's grief
and pain of maybe a lost uh uh loved one
or even you know just something tragic
that's happened to you what do you do
with that so it is uh it's a joy to have
Steve and ncol or Steve and Karen Nicola
here and they are great friends with my
parents I'm going to claim them as my
parents even though they're my in-laws
because I absolutely love them to death
they are as much as my parents is as my
own um but these guys are from where we
came from in California and um they came
and spoke at our church and it was a
absolute wonderful blessing because at
our church we actually had the pastor
who just lost his seven-year-old
daughter to cancer and our church was
grappling with what to do with this and
so um you guys were like a Divine
appointment showing up and I'm sure that
happens everywhere you go so welcome to
the show thank you Scotty thank you
Scotty happy to be here we are really
glad to be here yeah so tell us a little
bit about who you are and like how did
you get into this type of of ministry
I'll pass that off to Karen because
she's the one that started all this so
today we call ourselves grief Educators
and grief coaches it did begin
um years ago after our son our three and
a half-year-old son died of
Leukemia and I just didn't know where to
go I was 28 years old Steve is 28 years
old no one ever taught me how to
grieve and I asked that question you
know who taught you how to grieve well
right and most people like uh no one
right so for for me my relationship with
God was really all I had to hold on to
um and that's what I did I I just leaned
into into the Lord I leaned into his his
word and I found by doing so that there
was actual scripture written eons ago
ancient Biblical scripture that was
comforting to my broken Mama
heart over and over and over again again
mhm and So eventually that turned into
our book comfort for the day living
through the seasons of grief yeah tell
us a little bit about the book so so the
book um came forth as just this this
pressing urge to provide for people a
tool that would help them with their
broken heart it's it's not our story
it's not Dawson's story it's not about
his death and it's not even about our
healing or recovery it is is a place
that's Guided by scripture for each
reader to hear how God is healing them
so we look at the book as a bridge from
our grief to God from God's word to our
grief and how those synergize together
because either the words that he talks
about being able to comfort our our
Brokenness and our pain and our
suffering either those are real or
they're not right and we have chosen to
lean into it and say we have found from
experience God's word is faithful amen
yeah amen they're not memes you know
scripture verses are not memes like oh
that's a nice platitude oh that would be
nice somebody should hear that no this
is the
power heal that hurt yeah you know this
is the beautiful thing about the Bible
and I believe that there is a record of
all the experiences that have happened
on this planet because somebody's going
through that and the answers are there
and and how God worked through that situ
and sometimes you know people people
slam the Bible like oh there's these
awful things in the Bible yes but it
tells you that to show you what happens
if you go down that road but there's
plenty of stories I mean Adam and Eve's
child
firstborn is is is a murder and they
lost their second child I mean can you
imagine the grief that they experienced
at that point and so you know the Bible
all along the way is this awesome
Comfort Absolut and so what a beautiful
book well we we're learning because
grief is is indicative of the whole sin
problem it was an emotion that God never
intended human beings to ever experience
because death was something that we were
never intended to experience so we see
in in in in the book of of of Genesis
that everything was perfect we race down
to the end of Revelation and we see
Genesis you know Eden being restored but
there's a lot of junk in between and how
do we navigate that
and to us the gospel is restorative not
just for our sin problem but within the
sin problem our grief problem yeah our
lives a lot of people's lives I'm sure
take a Hiatus if you would or pretty
much stop when they have some tragedy
like that hit their home right and and
you know I I mean this story is now
becoming more and more common because we
know where the end of this thing's going
it's not getting better it's getting
more progressively you know the labor
pains if you would like Jesus described
it are going to get closer and more
intense and I think that this last
couple of years we've seen more death or
known people that have died than I I
don't remember that as a kid but it just
seems like this is going to not get
better I believe it is not going to get
better until until Jesus comes and so it
is critically important that we learn
the skills of mental health practice
practices that will that that
collaborate with the word of God the
principles of God's healing for us so
that we can live through really tough
times and um a lot of us have
experienced really tough times and I
really believe that again being a a
healed griver is like being a born again
Christian in some ways because when we
Are Born Again In Christ we have a
desire to share how the he is taking
place in our heart and so we we tell
people we don't do our ministry our B we
call it it we do a our we are a business
powered by Ministry amen is what we are
and so but we don't do it because we had
our our son died years ago we do it
because God has been faithful to heal
our our broken hearts and so we're here
today not as people that are saying man
is so terrible that our son died it is
there's no good spin on death yeah but
God is not willing to let death get the
last word yeah and he gets the last word
amen and you know what God often uses
somebody who's gone through that
experience because you're the best
person to go and talk to somebody that's
experiencing that thing um you know for
me uh you know I was hugely into
Hollywood and and and those kind of
things and when God kind of led me out
of that my initial like reaction to that
was well let me go and share with with
what God has God has opened my eyes to
and that hopefully can help some people
down the road so you know you guys
experiencing this this grief not that
God intended that on you at all or by
any means but you now are turning around
and blessing other people because you've
made it through that experience and you
see light at the end of the tunnel and
you want to share that with other people
and Scotty I'm so excited that you
invited us to this space because this is
now a conversation about healthy healing
grief that most people have no no
opportunity to have and so as we talk
about you know what makes grief um grief
and how we can engage with it in healthy
and healing ways you know that might be
the first time someone will have had an
alternative to drugging it numbing it
stuffing it distracting it overworking
it you see that's the way the what what
the culture tells us to do with our pain
is so it just adds to the pain it adds
to the darkness it takes the grief deep
deep deep but it doesn't bring it
healing so today we can have this
conversation about what brings the
healing yeah and the most important
thing we're seeing now is that even
though we have had you know we've had uh
the the experience of death of our of
our child I've lost a nephew to to
Suicide um I've just recently lost a
sibling my parents but just because
you've had a death experience of someone
that's close that's meaningful to you it
doesn't mean that you know how to help
someone else necessarily right so that
is the thrust of what Karen and I love
doing is walking into uh people's worlds
that are are going what do we do what do
we say what do we not say because it's a
learned behavior we're finding and it
should start at a very very young age we
believe we should be talking to four and
five year olds about what happened when
when fluffy died you know this you know
will and they want to know will I ever
see my pets again will I ever see
Grandpa or Grandma again or brother or
sister and we're not having those
conversations with our children and uh
as a former teacher that I've taught
everything from third grade to adult
inmates in prison I'm learning it's like
with sex education if we wait till
Junior High that I taught for too late
that was way too late and and the the
grief death experience should be an it
should be a normal conversation about an
abnormal situ thing that's happening
right that yeah I think what do you
think I mean aren't aren't parents a
little bit hesitant to even open that
maybe what they perceive to be can of
worms because it's a too painful for
themselves B they wouldn't know how to
answer the questions their kids might
have you know C they've never engaged
with their own grief in a healthier or
Healing Way and so you know parent child
conversations about this are almost zero
I mean if I sit and think about it and
as I was listening to you present this
weekend um you know I was like yeah do
do I even have like the tools do I even
know how to manage this and and deal
with this you're not alone in that
thought no and and and you know I like
that you brought up the idea of pets and
things because you know a lot of people
I mean who hasn't lost a pet right I
remember Burying my first goldfish right
my kids are so into animals and and you
know if I hit a squirrel driving in the
car I mean there's a half a day of grief
that
they even know the
squirrel and it's like yeah we need to
talk about these things and and so this
is this is why I really wanted you guys
to come on the show and and help us
understand because there are things that
you should and should not say and I was
pretty you know kind of fascinated my
wife was telling me a little bit she was
able to attend your afternoon meeting
and um you know she was telling me like
things that you should and you shouldn't
say and they're not they're not just
like you know things that I would have
not necessarily thought about and and
you don't know you're you're you're
saying the wrong thing you just think
you're being helpful but you know we
mean well and we understand that in
other words uh for anybody who's
listening and and that has had a
heartache or in grief and you've had
people say things that are hurtful
please know that they're not doing that
um intentionally right we we Comfort out
of what we know and many times that's
why we do the work we do so that there's
less pain for people that are hurting
already and frequently we comfort out of
our own fear MH our own
uncomfortableness and so then what what
we say trying to support somebody is
awkward and uh it's really all about us
and it's not about the person who we're
trying to comfort and so that was kind
that's the biggest transition if we can
recognize and just notice ourselves what
am I thinking am I thinking about my
fear my uncomfortableness my awkwardness
with someone else's pain or am I
thinking about them if if I choose to
think about them then my awkwardness
kind of just evaporates and I step into
the space where they are at and it's all
about them and it's not about me right
and that changes the dynamic which is
the heart of the Gospel exactly isn't
that true yeah yeah even when we're
dealing with grief I mean you still come
at it from a gospel perspective how is
this helping someone else not
necessarily just me right right so we're
willing to be misunderstood you see even
for the gospel and with and even in in
grief support we can be misunderstood
sometimes but when we realize that the
the griver has certain needs certain
wants certain um and they're very
they're very simple they just need to
know do you know that I'm in pain can
you just simply sit with me in my pain
so we look at like the Book of Job you
know and we think of job and his three
buddies that come over and they were
amazing comforters for the first week
yeah because why they gave really bad
they didn't even talk they never talked
Mike exactly they they were and then the
rest of the of job is is job struggling
with his grief his wife struggling with
her grief and these three guys that
think that they are they know better
than God about why job had it his
experience but people just simply need
to have people come and be in their
space of pain the police and the firemen
call it the power of presence think
about it I mean when you've had a major
loss we and we just we we wanted to call
it loss but when we've had a death let's
just call it what it is when we've had a
death of a loved one there are there's
not one word in the English language
that's going to bring you bring that
person back or make you feel better is
there right but think about it when
you've um when you've had a when you've
injured yourself you know you've hit
your thumb or you've fallen off the
ladder and and broke your leg or
whatever all you want to do at that
point is have people help you stop the
pain and no amount of talking to your
broken leg is going to make it feel
better right but there are people that
know how to apply medicines and
procedures that help you feel better and
so we have found that within the the the
grief arena there are certain things
that you can do that are simple like
just showing up and maybe bringing food
suggesting you could eat food with that
with those people that are grieving but
you give it's always about them would it
be okay if I stay a Nate with you or
should I just leave the meal with you
here I'm going to be stopping by next
week do you want to go out with me for a
bite to eat or would it be best if I
just came by and gave you a hug you see
and that could happen at any age you see
the this is the thing is that in a lot
of our work that we do in in businesses
or churches
the uh the average people that are there
of age are not they're they're they're
not young people under the age of 40
most of them are over that age as if
somehow grief is relegated just to
people in our in our generation you know
we're Baby Boomers um we have a strong
burden to to to educate clear down to to
you know element toddlers even they can
understand aspects of death maybe better
than we've given them credit for cuz
we've done it and um for years we've
gone down to Austin Texas area and
worked with a camp called Camp Agape and
there's also a great um program out on
the west coast now called um obis child
and it also works as a these are grief
camps that are free for any child for
kids that have lost uh a parent a
brother sister or grandparent and these
camps also have uh family camps that are
no cost um so they can get together and
talk about their grief but we learned
some things about children in grief
young people in grief because the obious
child um I mean um Camp Agape has the
ages of from like eight seven seven to
12 s to 12 and then camp Camp Agape goes
up to like
teenagers but children grieve
differently than we adults do so we
figure if they're running around and
happy they must be okay no that's just
how they deal with their grief they're
not going to display it like a yeah but
give they can move in and out of it
quickly more um quickly more naturally
they don't have to make a big trumpet
announcement I'm grieving right now or
I'm an active grief right now they they
just will start misbehaving or they'll
they'll they'll pull away or they'll
start to cry or they'll exhibit
something that is not their normal
behaviors and then if they're attended
to with that they'll move right back
into Happyland yeah and they can do that
you wonder if they don't care what other
people think maybe that kind of
contributes toit we're so guarded with
like you know what would people think if
I was just like telling a joke or
something you know maybe they'll think
that I'm insensitive or like you know
whatever goes on inside our mind where
it's to them they're not thinking of
those anies well children children like
Karen says internet in and go in and out
we've when we were down working with
some of our our um children in Texas you
know one moment we'd be we'd have a
special group activity that had them
thinking about their mom or dad that had
died and the tears the Waterworks were
just huge and then we'd say okay now
we're going to go outside and play GaGa
ball or or basketball or go play tag
okay or go fishing and they would turn
those tears off like a switch go wow
that's how kids do it here's the thing
we've also learned with children and
young people is that they generally
don't have the
vocabulary so if I came to Mikey and
said you know and I'd say I'm your child
and I'm four years old old and I've I'm
I'm suffering grief from the loss of a
significant loved one in my life I may
not be able to go you and tell you why
what I'm feeling I don't have the
adjectives of I'm feeling I'm feeling
confused I'm feeling angry I'm feeling
happy survivor's guilt orever they'll
act out in those ways their behaviors
will exhibit what their feelings are and
an interesting we've learned is as
children let's say if you have a child
who's lost a brother or a a sister or a
mom or a dad at a young age when they
don't have the vocabulary as they get
older and their developmental stages
grow um as they go into these different
stages of learning and of knowingness
they then reg Reeve the the death of
that because they now have words to put
with their with their feelings or they
now have
experiences that
are
very um real that they don't have their
brother or sister very reminding them
that they don't have that parent you
know think about an eighth grader who
whose dad died when he was in fifth
grade well eighth grade's kind of a big
deal and dad's not there yeah and he
goes on to high school and dad's not
there to all the games he plays and so I
don't have a dad yeah and that confessed
her um you know an uncomfortableness in
deep in his heart and soul that he might
not know what it's a tide to yeah and
but to but to attend to that
uncomfortableness that's inside of him
he might move towards pornography he
might move towards drugs he might move
towards you know overachieving and
becoming the best and so if you don't
deal with it yeah it's
still it won't go away it just exhibits
itself in a in an unhealthy way most of
the time so we need to be able to open
the door and let people know like we
need to deal with these things
especially if if if that's a trauma
that's as open as losing a parent or
something it's a difficult conversation
but a needed conversation that's what we
tell well that's what we're doing here
is we're just having a conversation that
needs to be had um you know we we didn't
create this problem but we're living it
aren't we yeah my my cousin passed away
um at age 42 of cancer and his um his
surviving wife and even their kids
actually live here in this area now
they're from California but they moved
out here and um my my dad's sister um
came out and she's a singer and she did
some music with her her grandchildren so
they'd be her grandchildren and they
were all up there and it was this
beautiful song and you know how siblings
voices match really well it was just
beautiful and my one thought was my
cousin wasn't here to see this and and
so I walked up afterwards and that was
the first thing I uttered out of my
mouth not I mean it just kind of came
out and I was like I wish your dad was
have seen this and immediately they weld
up you know and it was just like but
that was an appropriate thing to say
because it was the truth and it was from
your heart yeah yeah so and so if if
grieving Children and adolescents and
young adults recognize that they will
throughout their entire lifetime have
these moments that tears well up because
because their parent is not here right
now and rather than trying to sweep that
under their emotional rug you know just
be there in that pain and that's that's
the big deal it's our culture tries to
tell us to numit drug it stuff our pain
yeah they do anything with your pain but
feel it because Pain's the enemy right
grief is the enemy because grief is a
bad word because it's associated with
pain and when the culture puts that over
that and then they add scary elements of
you know ghost kinds of things and and
and return of the dead and zombies and
all the things that that so many teens
and young adults and are are just I mean
just thrown at you just thrown at you
it's really hard to duck out of the way
of it because it's just everywhere and
it can be benignly everywhere just Steve
was talking about his brother who died
just this last October October and his
birthday was a couple days ago and
somebody put on
Facebook happy birthday in
heaven well what a sweet little benign
thing to say sure but how confusing
right right if you really sit and think
about it it's like man that would be
really hard if you were in heaven
watching this mess down here how would
Heaven Be Heaven I mean I think it's
only merciful that people are not in
heaven that they're sleeping in the dust
of the Earth because you couldn't watch
what's going on here and especially if
if your surviving spouse you know has a
terrible end of her life or whatever I
mean it's like you would be miserable
yeah and so you know our our culture
just makes this this tries to make
death feel
better
or avoided and denied all together
because very rarely do they even use the
word death or die we talk about
transition they've moved on they've gone
to a better place it's it's a very
oxymoronic thing in this in this culture
because every Hollywood movie almost
every every series of te television
programs are involved around violence
and death aren't they and you guys know
that better than we do and yet when and
we we're entertained by Death by killing
by torture by mutilation that's put on
the screens and it's just expected but
if you were to see that in
person in and here's the problem is that
many people there's it's kind of a
two-edged stge some people are totally
horrified and repulsed by it in person
sadly though they're entertain by
it in in in real life there's no sense
of compassion or stopping it we just
going to take a sensitized to it well
now we play video games where you're
supposed to kill everybody in the room
and be the last person standing and
that's that's fun I mean that's just we
try to teach kids that all the time does
this seem like I mean if this was real
life and and Keith actually brought this
up one time to me um in talking about
video games he said if you put your
family members faces on those video game
players would you shoot
them and it was like wow that that just
brings a whole another context to it why
why why are we why are we doing that to
each other though I mean shouldn't we be
loving on each other and helping each
other and you know the heart of the
Gospel is like how can how can something
I'm doing help your life be better right
and that's what the and at and again the
the the violent videos and things are a
form of distraction yeah it is a form of
numbing and stuffing uh and there's a
lot of anger with a lot of kids in the
death of a of a parent or of a sibling
or of a buddy um just recently um just a
couple months ago I was was um I
happened to be home I was supposed to be
in Arizona with Karen doing a seminar
and I was I'd been sick that week and we
said it was best I not get on a plane
and help you help everyone else get sick
but I was by Friday I was feeling pretty
good but she'd already left so I spent
the weekend home well on Friday
afternoon I get a frantic call from a
local funeral director and she says I'm
I'm headed north back up to she was in
Modesto California with a team of um of
water Polo students from a local high
school and her son was on that team and
she says I've got the team in my my car
and we're headed back North we just got
word that one of their team members who
didn't come to the the water polo meet
has taken his life just a few hours ago
not days but just hours ago can you come
meet with us I said well I'm not a
trauma expert I only I mean I do best
with dealing with long-term grief and
she goes it doesn't matter we want you
there we had worked with this funeral
director before for and helping talk to
some other funeral directors and helping
teach classes for morticians and Funeral
Directors so she knew us and um so
anyway so that night I showed up at uh
at this home there in the Sacramento
area and um there was parents there was
pastors there was coaches and the whole
team sitting there quietly not knowing
what to do and it was then awn to me how
impactful the death of a teenager is on
other teenagers and how it radiates out
and so we just sat with our grief for a
while there we didn't say a lot but we
asked we started asking questions about
how was it with you guys and this this
other you know team member who who sadly
took his life and they said man he was
this great guy we really loved him and
he was a good he was a powerhouse on our
team but as we talk some more they
realized that maybe they hadn't been the
best team members or friends to him and
they could have done they could have
been more attentive to his needs so
there was a lot of of survivors guilt
and so we have a
strong um core urge to have schools and
and young people this is death is not
you know yeah we're the older guys right
um we may be older but we don't think
older we've worked we've worked with
kids for all our Liv yeah but we really
want teachers
administrators youth pastors Boys and
Girls Club
leaders um whether they're from a
religious background or non-religious
doesn't matter grief strikes everybody
doesn't matter what your background is
but young people need to know about how
to support each other how to deal with
this and can they look for the sign the
warning signs in a in a in another
friend around most people who take their
lives don't throw up flares and write
write it you know sometimes they'll post
things on Facebook or um you know
somewhere on Instagram or whatever
saying
I'm but we have to really listen and
take those those says seriously whenever
anybody starts talking about self harm
we don't go well hey man I'm here for
you no we we go and we risk being
misunderstood at that time and we get
them we we go talk to somebody who's a
professional and says I have a friend
who's thinking about taking his life and
we bring that person into the program
into the scene now that buddy of yours
may say man I had no I was just goofing
off man I was just kidding I didn't mean
that man now you look you got these
people involved my parents are all
freaked out um it's been said I would
rather not be your friend than attend
your
funeral and that's and that's what we're
talking about here is is we're saving a
lot of Heartache when we can be
proactive in there we're not here to
necessarily talk about suicide but it
certainly has ramifications that go on
for a very very long time in my early
20s um I was friends with a with a kid
that was in Hollywood and he was about
my same age and he was starting to
really book a lot of um acting gigs he
had a place in Beverly Hills he was
friends with other famous actor people
and and um there three there was three
of us that were kind of always like
friends and hanging out together and
stuff and um I hung out with them on a
weekend some some weekends we would go
find some pool to get into or something
and um two days later he hung himself in
his apartment and I tell you it it was
difficult for me to wrap my head around
that because you know um I grew up
learning about Christianity and had a
lot of knowledge in my head about this
war between Christ and Satan and and I
knew a lot and my friend was looking
into Buddhism and he was constantly
inviting me over to his house like let
me tell you about my like you know what
I'm finding out about this faith and
that and I said nothing to him nothing
not a word didn't tell him about my
faith didn't tell him what I believe
didn't say anything so when he died that
realization of like like I didn't I did
he reached out to me and I didn't say
anything to him and so it it actually
really contributed to when when God won
my heart back and we started with little
light the name little light was
literally because I H hid my light under
a bushel and I told I I told not my
friends and so I made a covenant with
God and I said you know what I will be
as bold as you want me to be God I will
never hide what you've taught me ever
again beautiful somebody asks I will
tell them and that's that's really where
little light the name came from it's
just like little song so yeah and and
it's and it's you know grief that I
didn't know how to process through but I
certainly felt guilty for it down the
road well honey talked to to Scotty
though about that what we think is one
of the biggest aspects of of healing
grief because imagine that Scott has a
lot of of regrets yeah some self blame
about not saying something and there's
an answer for that too we talked about
that earlier a little bit about the this
whole area of no matter how bad we've
blown it and maybe we felt that our our
behaviors led to our our contributed to
or at least we didn't say thing is the
area of forgiveness yeah and so so grief
to me is is not a straight line that
starts at one space and then it ends you
know five stages down the road which so
many of us get you know that's the
impression that that we're that we're
given so we we kind of see it more as a
spiral and things keep repeating mhm and
it might be a year or two and it comes
back and it hits us or whatever
and it repeats really intense right at
the beginning just just over and over
and over again but the the life
experience like I spoke about this last
weekend that has to do with receiving
forgiveness for those regrets for those
what have could have should have would
have if only that we have in our life
that that we that we take responsibility
for God
says I don't want you to carry that
burden because you are never intended to
carry that burden and that's what my
death is for is to fully display to you
how much how far I've gone to forgive
youh and to forgive you and there
there's there's nothing left
undone from the cross there there's
there's there's no sin that get that
didn't get nailed to that cross there's
no mistake there's no what have could
have should have that that didn't didn't
get nailed to that
cross and um so we're
redeemable after those moments where we
realize maybe I did play a part in
someone's life that brought them more
trauma maybe not to the point of death
but maybe you know they died and I
omitted something that I wished like you
the story you're talking about so I'm so
grateful that in this spiral when when
we see this the word forgiven is kind of
bold and it is the life experience in
our bereavement
spiral that changes our grief from
something that's unhealthy in the center
of that core that we just can't get past
that we get stuck at or that it trips us
up and
um
man I am
forgiven I discovered that I was
forgiven for my mama
mistakes there's no perfect parent
there's no perfect friend no perfect
husband or wife we all blow it and to be
to be forgiven just leaves my heart free
yeah and that's the gospel that's what
Jesus invites us into and then he wants
us to live in this this cycle of
forgiveness where we receive forgiveness
and we give forgiveness and now I'm
finding that in an ordinary
day when I say and do really stupid and
hurtful things to my husband because I'm
only thinking Mah you know I'm just
thinking about me or what I'm thinking
about at the time and I don't think
about oh maybe I should say this
differently to this amazing man I love
and it's and so I'm finding that I I'm
much Freer to go hey honey I'm really
sorry can you forgive meh and and to
give and ask for forgiveness sooner than
just omitting it you know that's awful
we don't we're not supposed to go to bed
at the end of the day with unfinished
business so let's finish the business as
it goes along and it's
interesting when we you see the spiral
there because this is we might as well
say as long as we've got a chance here
that most people are familiar with the
five stages of grief and this is also an
aspect that because people don't
understand it it they get stuck and they
get
confused um there was a um a u I think
she was from U Denmark or Austrian or Dr
Elizabeth scuer Ross and I'm trying to
remember what nationality she is right
now but anyway she uh she studied people
and back in the 60s who were given a
death a terminal diagnosis terminal
diagnosis you know Fred we're so sorry
but you have lung cancer you'll probably
live a year or you know Betty it's this
is terrible you've got pancreatic cancer
maybe six months and those people went
through the five stages of grief most of
them she found that there was a
consistency there so there was there was
shock there was denial there was anger
there was bargaining and then there was
like okay I've I i' there's nothing I
can do about it so they there's in in
many of them there's a resolution and
that was that was a pattern that she saw
in thousands of dying patients but you
notice it was the word is dying patients
those people had an end they had a
beginning and they had an end to their
but their family
members they don't have the same five
stages of grief because it's all over
the map it's very very messy and it's
very unpredictable so I mean I for me I
said well you I told people for years
I'm not angry guess what I was M or I'm
not you know I'm not now did I bargain
yeah I bargain too but I also had a
plethora of different emotions that keep
recycling themselves and it was
confusing when I kept thinking it was a
it was linear when really it's there's
nothing linear to grief at all and when
children and young people and adults can
understand that grief is really
unpredictable and when I know that and I
know that in you let's say you've had a
major L Scotty or Mikey you've had
I can give you all kinds of of latitude
all kinds of Grace cuz I'm not wait a
minute you know you're so and so died
you know you your whatever died and I
know that you know you were kind of
angry the other day so we'll check that
one off and then months later why are
you angry again you see and so once I
know that record exactly and it's a bit
warped you know those warp because used
to yeah yeah yeah cuz grief is is messy
yeah it's true and not a straight line
no it's disorganized it's chaotic it's
totally
unpredictable and I just want to back up
just a moment because I think that if we
only talk about our grief in
relationship to death yeah we've missed
this is true a whole bunch of grieving
brokenhearted people yeah could be loss
of a marriage could be you know like
just you you you harmed someone or
someone hared you or yeah break up with
a boyfriend a girlfriend you know the
our parents divorce there's a loss of a
marriage we could lose our abilities
because we got in a car accident and now
one leg is an inch shorter than the
other and I can't run and I've always
been a runner that is such a loss you
know a pet can die we we can lose our
job and be fired which then is a whole
cascading thing about you know what's
what's my identity I mean I was so tied
into who I was at work because that's
how we identify ourselves you know so
what do you do that's the first thing qu
question people ask so so like for
retiring particularly for men when they
retire and suddenly they don't longer
have a job title yeah they're they're
rudderless you because they have been
defined by what they do not who they are
so we can lose our identity we can lose
our faith hope and and and Trust we can
I think every person on the planet has
lost their innocence in one degree or
another from one cause or another mhm um
it's amazing that we're having this
conversation like less than 24 hours
after what I felt last night my mom had
a stroke uh going on three years ago now
and it really messed with her it was
called a Wes aasia and so she can't even
make a sentence she needs a a sitter my
dad I'm I'm an only child so there's
guilt with that when I can't help my dad
um and so my you know my dad he still
has to work he's not retirement age yet
so he actually has to take my mom to a
friend God bless her soul she watches my
mom wow and then but she's not in her
right mind so she's you know a lot of
stroke people they U maybe they're weak
on one side or something my mom can get
up and walk right out the door and you
don't realize how how many things are in
your house that are like dangerous like
she could go to some cleaner and start
to try and drink it because she doesn't
understand and so this has happened 3
years ago and literally last night like
you're talking about the what triggers
it last night I was putting my dishes
away and when I put a spoon there was in
my drawer there's like small spoons and
big spoons and I had a big spoon in my
hand and I almost put it in the small
and I was like oh no it goes in the with
the big and it just like this it
triggered something about my mom like
when we put dishes away together and I
was like wow I missed my Mom it just hit
me like all of a sudden this just
happened last night and and I was
like all these thoughts of
like the times that I wouldn't answer
the phone when she called because I knew
I'd be on the phone with her for an hour
or something I'm like or I wish I could
talk to my mom for an hour you know yeah
of course thanks for sharing that that's
that's huge how many
people are walking around chat nooga mhm
with multiple
losses that maybe are not death but you
know Dementia or the loss of mind or the
loss of physical abilities and they have
family members and loved ones that are
going through that experience and
carrying that pain um you know every
person we meet whether it's the the
teller at the coffee shop or whether
it's the grocery guy or whether it's all
hurting yeah the agent of the airport
just until just now I didn't know that
about you you see how could I know see
Mikey doesn't have any external wounds
there's no there's no bruises there's no
he doesn't have any cuts and a grieving
person doesn't have it on the outside
generally they can make a you know maybe
a really sad face or something but n the
time we just kind of buck up and yeah
you just you life goes on what what I
what I hear you saying though is that
you've had start saying goodbye to your
mom because the essence of your mom her
mind has now gone hasn't it yeah and her
body's still here and it's still
functioning yeah and so and in our world
that it's called anticipatory grief you
know we we grieve we're already grieving
what we know is coming down the road but
we're also grieving what could have been
and when your mom was whole mentally
emotionally spiritually physically and
those are those are could have would
have should have that we have to say I
could have done better but I can't go
back and do a doover and giving
ourselves Grace is is probably one of
the hardest things that many people do
we you know we we will say you know God
can forgive me but I can't forgive
myself and that's we hear that a lot
that concept you brought up this weekend
and that was like a real I sat and
thought about that for a long time
God said he forgives
you and we're the ones that are like
no I don't want to be forgiven see the
God doesn't condemn you for not
answering the phone I you know most of
us get that you know and so we realize
that God still loves us CRA he's
absolutely crazy about us that then we
can begin to extend Grace to ourselves
and you having gone through this
experience has you know as as harmful
you not harmful but as painful as it
is you get it better than a lot of other
people who are also going to go through
the same situation and now not because
God said why need Mikey to be able to
help other people who have parents that
are dealing with with this but now
here's one more person on planet Earth
that can be a center of healing for
those people that are just kind of
rudderless that are trying to where do I
go with this yeah like you said there's
no good spin on death had a death of a
daughter as well uh two years ago I had
a job experience kind of thing but it's
like God cancern everything for good
what Satan means for evil God didn't
cause these things but he can turn turn
around for good now you have a Ministry
now you can identify with people you
know uh I have a past of addiction so I
can talk to people who are in Act of
addiction whereas the straight La pre
preacher who's never tried it they're
not going to listen to him um so yeah
what what the enemy means for evil God
can turn around for good and I like how
you talked about these promises that
they're not just memes that they're
they're real thing um we have a guest on
here often his name is Eric Wilson and
he through this grief he really taught
me the power of God's promises he's like
put your name in that promise this isn't
just something like for the for Israel
back then this is you every every
promise in the Bible is for you and you
have to claim it and know that it's true
not just well I hope this is true or I'm
going to you know claim this as a good
thought or something but it's true you
know and can I give you a word picture
for this because after our son died and
I don't know what it was like for you
with your daughter after she died but my
life my actual physical home our
property where we lived it seemed like
the
enemy had backed his dump truck full of
stinky rotten garbage and just dumped it
entirely over our living
space and you can't escape it you know
you can't escape something like that MH
and then I began to discover just how
God is this amazing divine
he takes the garbage and the pain that
happens in our lives and he redesigns it
into some masterful artwork you know
have you seen those sculptures that have
come out of the junk keep you know there
there's children down in South
America and they make actual orchestra
instruments W and they have an entire
Orchestra made out of things that came
out of their garbage heap and made play
this beautiful music it's just so
profound how something that was
discarded trashed stinky horrible is
rescued and can make beautiful music and
so when I when we see that our God is so
much more creative than than the
darkness of the evil one you know God
just says step aside I'm making some
gorgeous thing out of this thing and he
tells it can I read it from Isaiah
because this is this is so so so so cool
um he
says for those that are grieving Jesus
came to comfort us to heal our broken
hearts to support us to set us free from
our prisons of Darkness of unforgiveness
all of that kind of stuff and to comfort
for those who mourn and he says I want
to give them who's the them all of us
all of us G brokenhearted just piled up
with all this garbage he says I'm going
to give
them crowns of beauty instead of
Ashes I'm going to give them oil of Joy
instead of tears of
grief I'm going to give them clothes of
Praise instead of garments of Despair so
that's how creative God can be with the
pain that the evil one
wants to wipe us all out with and I just
say thank you Lord for providing a
snorkel yeah that I can still keep
breathing the atmosphere of Heaven under
this garbage heap because it even gets
better than that he says they will be
called Oaks of
righteousness the planting of the Lord
so that he can display his glory yeah
it's like okay so we are all the display
of his glory because we're letting him
recreate Beauty amen out of our ashes
amen and you guys come from the land of
Oaks there in California so when you see
a massive
Oak I often found myself under an oak
tree huge oak tree and you just look up
into that thing and you just go it's
immovable it's how long has this thing
been here like it's just this solid
piece of thing well and it Prov so much
shelter I mean think of think of the
beauty of of Our Lives being the shelter
for others who are broken and wounded
that need to come under its shade they
need to come under its comfort and this
is yeah did I originate this idea yeah
yeah no no God did yeah amen so amen I'm
I'm leaning that way God's way that's
one of the promises that I have in in a
book that I wrote Because not a book I
wrote it my journal prayer Journal but I
didn't used to keep one and and that was
the the Silver Lining or how God turned
something painful into something good I
became dependent upon God I had no one
else you know no one can make you feel
like they understand or whatever and
that was one thing I was curious about
some of the stuff you had about things
to say or not to say
because I had people calling messaging
on every platform and everything and I
didn't want to talk to anybody I just
reused back but I tell people don't not
do it though because I I got to see how
many people really cared and and things
like that they do see it don't they
muggy yeah oh yeah we're seeing it you
know you see those messages but you're
not ready to read or respond or and then
people would bring food and put that on
your porch and that was amazing because
you don't feel like doing anything you
don't feel like eating let alone cooking
no exactly well if I can interject I'll
get back to you those that are listening
that are supporting someone like Mikey
who has had a a tragic death in their
family um don't stop showing up yeah
they are reading your text they are
reading your emails they are eating the
food that you drop by they just don't
have the bandwidth to write you some
flowing thank you note for your for what
you've done it's not about us it's about
The Grieving individual and that's what
the gospel Jesus keeps giving and giving
and giving and with nothing in return
I'm sorry go ahead Mike I just wanted to
interject that because cuz you are
you're exactly what what I've had to
learn over the years is that there's
enough of my my broken Humanity that
says oh I brought Mikey some food he
didn't say thank you he
didn't so we there's a part of us that
wants to say you know we want to kind of
you know throw up a flare or post it you
know look at you I look at these guys
that are helping the the homeless people
and they've got here I am helping this
person I'm giving him money and I'm
going I don't think I I just cannot
imagine Jesus filming himself as he's
Healing The Man by the pool of Bethesda
you know boy this will look good at six
o'clock tonight and and I'm a video guy
like I I I want to see this thing play
out right and we've actually brought
video cameras when we went downtown
remember that one time we started hand
and food for the commercial were you
with us that gyc commercial it was years
ago and we were filming us giving food
to the homeless people and I tell you
there's no more awkward feeling like you
feel like I'm just taking something from
rather than giving something to them I'm
wanting their situation to help my
something down the road and it was a bad
feeling I remember that starkly yeah
well let's talk about some of the things
that people say and don't understand
that they could say something better um
I think one of the the common responses
that we all reach out with is I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry well let's just think
about that for a moment who is that
statement
about who is it about yourself yeah it's
about me it's about me but if I'm going
to be a really effective comforter it
needs about you right so it's a simple
thing it's such a simple thing all we do
is we complete that
sentence I'm so sorry that your daughter
died Mikey I'm so sorry that your
parents have struggled I'm so sorry that
your dog got run over I'm so sorry that
you've lost your job I'm so sorry you
see we and then now who is it about yeah
the person it's about them simple tweak
and we're acknowledging we just finish
the sentence yeah just to finish one
thing if I'm just not even really sure
what the tragedy or the loss might be I
just say I'm so sorry this is so
difficult right now you know and and
then it's not about me I've acknowledged
that it is about them because when you
say I'm just so sorry initially then you
you're you're saying oh it's okay it's
okay I'm doing okay you know we're
getting along okay because now you're
trying the person that we're trying to
say we're so sorry to now they start
supporting they start coming back and
trying to tell us that they're going to
I'm sorry that my trauma has put you in
a bad sit exactly exactly Scotty you
you've nailed that so the other thing
that often is um a myth about traumas
and losses and grief is the phrase Time
Heals all
wounds so you don't like that
I mean I mean I know that that's you're
trying to be kind when you say something
like that like like like I know no one
is thinking ill thoughts but I've said
that before you know like you know just
give it a little bit of time and it'll
be better it's like many people are like
I don't want it to be to to get better I
wanted this other thing instead of what
I got you know exactly so number one
time healing is a myth and one of the
ways the easiest for us to really get
this
is if you had something growing fuzzy
stuff and making a really bad stink in
your
refrigerator how much time would it take
for that bad stink and fuzzy stuff to
just go away yeah when the refrigerator
breaks and
dies so there's no amount of time that's
going to clean the stink out of the
refrigerator right so what cleans the
stink out of the refrigerator a human
being using their time to clean it out
yeah now when I read my
Bible I read that God heals broken
hearts he's the Healer in his time he
does all things well in his time good so
it's not my time it's not this planet's
time that heals our wounds makes us all
better it's us in the heart and the
hands of God who will do that so we've
learned to say you when people say well
Time Heals we just say well I I
appreciate that we've learned that time
doesn't heal but God does that's a good
that's a good response because I I've
met people over the years that have been
traumatized early on in their life and
I'll tell you what uh you they'll talk
about it like it happened yesterday and
that's 30 years ago you know so yeah I
think to your point it's like yeah time
is not necessarily just the factor that
how's that working for them yeah you're
exactly right Scotty right right yeah so
th those are a couple things that that
people just kind of naturally say the
the one that is probably tossed out
there Aon is call me if you need
anything oh yeah yeah yeah I'll get
right on that you know I'm going to make
a phone call to you and request
something I'm feeling bad well I mean
people probably said that have said that
in years recently to you Mikey haven't
they how many you know or um you know
let me know if you need anything and I
we always say that is a blank check that
nobody is ever going to cash yeah
because it makes us feel better exactly
it's all well it's it's a safe thing to
say we can walk away going I man I said
hey Mikey if you need anything
man and but the The Grieving mind is not
capable of thinking through what they
need so don't come with a problem that's
a problem yeah but come with the
solution yeah hey Mikey I'm going to be
I'm going to be swinging by your house
and um I noticed that you've got your
your lawn's looking pretty ratty man I
can just throw my my lawnmower in the
back would it be okay if I swing by and
uh and and just do some quick mowing
that' be okay and he may say no no it's
just I I I like it long yeah you know I
you know obviously I could just show up
and to start doing it and you probably
wouldn't be too bad but maybe the noise
of a mow is just not what Mikey wants to
hear right now so we always keep even
our generosity about the other person
whether it's a generosity of our time
our means uh whatever it still has to be
about the person who you don't know if
their child was the last one to use that
lawnmower and you know they don't want
to take it out of the garage cuz that
just reminds them of that
always be sensitive to to the other
person and respect what they say but
yeah offer but there's another reason
why we ask permission even ask hey do
you take
hugs be sure because some are Huggers
and some are not yeah and we don't want
to add that additional discomfort to
somebody right I make that mistake all
the time I mean like like I'm just
naturally a small bubble I I'm a I'm a
you know touching feel that's my love
language right and so I just naturally
go up to people and you know you see
somebody downcast or whatever and like
let me give you a hug let me make that
better and I mean you've you've seen
those people that just like Bo like okay
yeah yeah the boundary here so the the
quickest thing we say is just simply
would you take a hug yeah just ask that
ask permission and I've had people say
no yeah ask permission no problem but
part of that asking for permission is to
help The Grieving person reestablish
control in their life M because when a
child dies when your mom has a stroke
when other traumas take place in our
lives feels we lost control you know I
my son died and and I couldn't control
that I couldn't stop that and now I
can't stop the Cascade of things that
have to happen next and so that feeling
of loss of
control often doesn't get identified it
doesn't get oh I've lost control and and
so supportive friend friends can really
help to give that control back by asking
permission that's an excellent point
those all those little areas for where
someone who's just overwhelmed with with
the loss and the devastation and the
pain and the Nightmare and the the the
complete and total change in their
life you still have some options on the
table and you're giving that person that
respect to make that choice and that's
what we work with in our in our practice
that we do we let people know there's so
much in your life that's happened to you
that you can't control but here's some
things that you can do to regain control
of the things that are important for you
and how you take care of your diet your
exercise when you go to bed uh what you
watch what you read what you put into
your mind those are things that you can
control now interestingly enough um
particularly with men but just happens
women too the very Act of asking for
help
is difficult will be a a a reminder of
I'm not in control of my life I need
help and that's one more thing I've got
to admit I don't have control over I
need help and so when people are not
asking for help that need to be asking
for help okay we maybe see a friend
who's he's just he's just or she's just
in in their room they've got the shades
drawn they don't answer their phone
they're not coming to the door that's
serious so we need to friends need need
to just show up like the four friends
that Dro their buddy down through the
roof in front of
Jesus D we're going and we need to be
there and so um let's be aware of people
who are who are in grief and what they
might need and it's again Mikey was
talking earlier about you know I didn't
want to respond to people who were
reaching out to me but I liked it at the
same time to know that someone was
thinking about me if I if I heard you
right I I want to hang on that thought
that just mentioned the guy's drip
dropping down in the in the um roof
because he brought up some things um um
that I had not really thought of before
them obviously not letting this
individual in the space um probably he
did some bad things and people were like
M you're not getting in here you know
what I mean he's asking for help maybe
they've seen or heard that Jesus can
heal people and they still weren't going
to part and let this guy in right you
know and and the fact that his friends
did not just take that as like sorry man
you made your own bed and you got to
sleep in it but they were proactive and
they moved forward with faith and God
honored that is is also something that
you know as somebody is grieving or has
has some you know unforgiveness or or
something like that as friends we can
also help out in those those situations
Scotty good point good point yeah bring
bringing our friends to Jesus even if
they don't know we're bringing them to
Jesus right right bringing them the
goodness I want to go back to the
control idea
when we feel like we have lost control
in whatever it is that we are
experiencing one of the things that we
can have absolute control over is how we
take care of our bodies and because our
bodies do actually respond to the trauma
it absorbs it it's not just an emotional
head thing it's a full head to toe thing
and so one of the features in our book
explains how we grieve
physiologically we grieve emotionally
physically and spiritually and so our
physical grief is something that we can
attend to we can do something with that
like if we are suffering with insomnia
we can do certain things like um like um
taking a a warm bath having you know
some teas taking a walk kind of winding
down for the night and um maybe having
someone pray with us and read scripture
for us in our evening time maybe if our
insomnia continues for a while we can
use that time to to put in our prayer
journal and so by releasing things even
in the middle of the night in our prayer
Journal we can often go right back to
sleep or let's say we are experiencing
just aches from head to toe and the body
does that we just ache from head to toe
we feel like we've been run over by a
Mac Truck well we we our body is is
absorbing and col collecting all the
toxins of the stress so we need some
exercise to walk that out and so we can
go for a walk I can choose to do that
yeah and I know I'm making a good choice
for myself I can choose to eat foods
that are going to help my immune system
because my immune system is going to be
shot for about 12 months so you see we
can regain control in our grief
experience starting with the physical
needs in our life
walk pretty simple I mean most people
can do that most people in fact the
things that we can do that are most
helpful are absolutely free and that's
walking and the other one is putting
your stuff on
paper and so and and that's what comfort
for the day living through the seasons
of grief is all about it's about letting
God's
scripture you have some pages in here to
write stuff down help us put our stuff
on paper and we don't we ask people
please don't write anymore yeah don't
Journal because writing has to do with
academics that's all about being
organized and neat and good handwriting
and keeping the rules and making sure
the sentence is right and the paragraph
is right but we just said grief is messy
disorganized chaotic
unpredictable so that's what we put on
paper and we don't write we just put
that pain on paper we put that messy on
paper we put that disorganized could be
a doodle oh it could be AB could be as
the tears fall on the page you're
drawing circles around it and commenting
on it there's there's there's a place
for the absolutely because that
expression that
release gives us space for healing to
come inside and when this kind of
activity is
stimulated by the healing word of
God ah
then where it was wherever my heart was
that particular day wherever I am in
that bereavement spiral that speaks to
me and that gets healed for that day now
I might spiral back to that again and it
might speak to me differently on another
day and we don't need to feel guilty if
we do spiral back see we we have to let
people know that grieving and grief is
not and what happened to you was not a
lack of faith many of us that have been
raised in a Christian home and a
Christian environment and Christian
schooling when these bad things happen I
even I did that I thought man did my son
die because I didn't pray hard enough
did I have unknown sin in my life that
prevented God from from um I don't think
God can can work with us when we have
rebellious sin in our lives if I'm in
outright Rebellion I can on the one hand
be rebellious against God on the other
hand expect him to come through the road
hes when I need him but if you I
remember I remember starting to think
was there something that I did when I
was mean here I am out in the front of
my my my home up in the S Nevada
mountains pleading with God for my son's
life and I'm saying well did I did I say
something or do something when I was 13
you know that I can't remember that I
never asked for God's forgiveness for
and and would he not heal my son because
I can't remember that
sin I didn't know the heart of God that
God doesn't work that way he knows that
we're but dust he tells us in
Psalms that God was was there with me
out in the front of my house laying on
the ground with me weeping with
me see I hate this this is wrong I never
planned
this I never planned for a three and a
half year older mhm how old was your
daughter she was 15 but she was like an
infant yeah
and that was never both the birth and
the and the death the condition of birth
was never ever God's plan so when we we
hear people say well God has a
plan if this is God's plan he plan he's
a terrible planner you see God is a
restorer of what was robbed from right
that was rightfully his he's restoring
but he has to let it play out and he
says I am I I am not don't have plans to
harm you right and that said in jerem
yeah to give you a hope in a future have
come that you will have life more
abundantly and you know there's there's
Concepts in there that it's like people
want to attribute like God why did you
let this happen and I know that that's
the number one thing that people always
attribute like God you have the power
you should have stopped this or you
didn't stop it or whatever but but an
enemy's done this there's an enemy who's
sewn tears in here and an enemy that's
taken this and God has to let this thing
play out in in certain areas and certain
ways and you know it's like we're
working with a lot of dynamics that we
don't fully understand exactly Scot and
even in your child's life you know I see
it as like what if God said at this
moment I can take this child to heaven
we don't know what the end would be from
the beginning he does and maybe there's
some choices down the road but at this
moment this child can be mine and and
and and he allows God wins in that
situation and and and at the end of the
day our job is to just say God you're a
righteous judge you made the right
choice some you save some you don't and
I'm going to accept however you did that
and i' I mentioned in our seminar this
weekend I've tell our clients this that
is do we know see this is this is so
important to know the heart of God and
to know the character of God because if
I can take maybe I only have four things
that I know to be I know that are
unequivocally true about God and you
can't change my mind about any no amount
of money no amount of arguing or
studying with me I know these things to
be
true I'm going to take that and utilize
that I'm going to lay that over what I
don't know amen you see I don't know why
my I don't know why Mikey's daughter
died I don't know why my son died
there's not a there even if I knew why
so now I know why how did that change
you see but so then can we as as as
Christians can we go to the
kingdom with unanswered questions is
that okay see that's not a heretical
statement that's just simply there's an
infinite amount of things that we will
spend eternity un unearthing right so if
that's if it's going to take eternity
our little three score and 10 is not
enough time so God's saying don't think
about all things you don't know about me
take the things you know to be true
non-negotiable yeah and the bottom lay
it sounds and it sounds almost like a
throw away turn God is love Yeah but we
work from that and then everything else
we believe and teach and and and and are
is a doctrine of scripture those are
based in God's love and goodness toward
us he's not willing that one would be
lost and so when we get to heaven we're
going to look back at this thing we're
going to go he did every single thing he
could have possibly done there was
nothing else he could have tried there
will be there will not one voice I
believe in heaven that say God you
should have done it like this you could
have done more you could have done more
God one voice every tongue will profess
even the evil tongues
God you did it right and I got what I
deserved and and this is my choice and
you gave me my choice as hard as that
was for you God as much as that hurts
your heart he gave me what I wanted
every tongue you guys this has been a
beautiful conversation and I know you
guys have to catch a plane so uh you
know I I I'm sorry we didn't we didn't
have you here longer earlier next time
you're in town I would love for you guys
to well you can see it's our passion yes
it is our passion because because it's
it's something that God is is saying
there's a problem but there's a solution
amen and the solution is in God's word
amen in God's heart the solution is not
in us talking about it yeah the solution
is allowing God into our minds and into
our hearts and saying I can work in
there and I can do the healing that
needs to take place amen and that
healing may be painful at times he may
say you know there are some things in
your closet in your heart that are just
not helping the healing
process if a person's actively using
substances we won't we generally don't
work with people who are who are
alcoholics or drug addicts we will work
with some of them because those things
have short circuited the emotions and
people need to feel they need to feel
the The Angst the grief the pain of
their choices maybe and or of the death
of a loved one or of whatever number of
things they're
grieving um and I say that carefully
because where are there are some that we
do work with that as long as they are in
a treatment plan or going to Alcoholics
Anonymous and they're they're relatively
clean and sober we can work with that
but when we are trying to find healing
for our grief but on our own trying to
medicate it through whatever means those
are those don't work together where
we've learned so as Educators and like
how would somebody get in touch with you
guys you have a website podcast do how
would somebody get this book as a gift
for somebody who's grieving our uh our
our website is Comfort forthe day.com
okay and all the information to get in
touch with this is at Comfort forthe
day.com we're at Facebook at comfort for
the day we're also on YouTube um under
my name Karen Nicola what do you do on
YouTube do you have podcasts do you I
don't have any podcasts um but just a
series of videos little videos I make
myself videos of like a service that we
spoke at like yesterday will show up
there so there's there's quite a few
little things that you can just share
with a friend or just bless yourself
with so Karen Nicola YouTube or Comfort
forth day Facebook comfort for
theday.com yeah and on our website is a
a
beautiful grief support program that
people can invest in that they can use
for as long as they need to and it's
called grief you have options and it's
like having a personalized grief coach
which in this case would be Karen and me
in some of the segments there's about 25
of them oh wow and people can any time
of the day or night access these in any
order there's no order to it just like
with our book we tell people there's no
order to go through the book and there's
downloadable PDFs that will allow people
to interact with the whatever deeper and
to take in what they saw in the video
and to apply it to their lives
personally so we're super excited about
grief you have
options um video support grief support
you guys so thankful for that what a
beautiful Ministry that you have and
honestly um I hate to inform you that
you're probably going to get busier as
time goes on yeah Weir but I'll tell you
what it it's been an absolute joy to
hear you not only speak but that you
came by and and were able to bless us
thank you Scotty and Mikey so much for
for asking us to be here uh your
questions and your insights and your
stories were were certainly encouraging
us too awesome if you guys and I'm just
going to go out on a limb here are
hurting or know somebody that is hurting
I want you to please look into comfort
forthe day.com and look these guys up if
you know of somebody that would benefit
from even just this conversation please
share this conversation with somebody
and um there is some valuable valuable
advice and I know we we've only been
here for an hour and it's like I want to
keep going so um thank you guys for
stopping by and uh we hope that you were
blessed by today's conversation and um
share this video and if you haven't uh
seen any of our other videos feel free
to thumb through our our YouTube page
and uh if you really like what you see
there then uh consider uh subscribing to
our Channel where we're always trying to
put out you know chist centered good
media that really inspires people like
these two have said with getting into
the word of God that's the true source
of power so I hope and pray that you
guys will find healing and that uh that
God is the source of that so thank you
for watching we'll see you guys next
week do you have questions about the
Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your
[Music]
journey every day is an opportunity to
show kindness to the
[Music]
world every day is an opportunity to do
something
that let someone know you're thinking of
them every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in
[Music]
return every day is an opportunity to
notice someone in need to go out of your
way to help
them every day is an opportunity
to do one small
thing to show someone you
care to make the world a better
[Music]
place